to be here at Millen lunch Club in
Hertfordshire joining volunteers now
this is part of a big help out tens of
thousands of events taking place across
the country just like this respecting
and reflecting that his Majesty's long
tradition of service and it's Community
Spirit like this that binds our country
together it's fantastic to be a part of
it here today and help out myself now on
the weekend I think no other country in
the world could put on such a dazzling
spectacle and it was a proud expression
of our history our culture our
Traditions but also a reflection of the
modern character of our country it was
deeply moving to be in the coronation
service and Incredibly uplifting and
it's the experience I think that nobody
will forget for the rest of their lives
the police used Powers your government
is introduced to arrest 64 protesters on
Saturday what kind of a message does
that send to the world about the UK well
the the police are operationally
independent of government they'll make
these decisions based on what they think
is best and actually I'm grateful to the
plea face and everyone who played a part
in ensuring that this weekend has gone
so well so successfully and so safely
that was an extraordinary effort by so
many people and I'm grateful to them for
all their hard work you've probably also
had a chance over the weekend to reflect
on the local elections on Friday morning
you said they were disappointing that
turned out to be a massive
understatement didn't it well if I I
know that people want us to deliver for
them on their priorities I know that's
not going to happen overnight but we are
going to strain every sinew to do
exactly that to halve inflation grow the
economy reduce their cut waiting list
and stop the boats I believe those are
the country's priorities those are my
priorities and I'm going to work night
and day to deliver on them for everyone
will you apologize to the more than a
thousand councilors who lost their seats
always disappointing to lose hard
working third of counselors and I said
that at the time you know my job is to
deliver for the country and we've got a
big team of people determined to do that
we want the half inflation grow the
economy reduce their cut waiting list
and stop the boats those are the
countries priorities and me and the
government are going to keep working
incredibly hard to deliver on those
you've announced measures today to help
deal with the kind of atam scramble of
GP surgeries up and down the country I
mean the real problem here though is a
lack of doctors isn't it how are you
going to fix that what we do have
actually at the moment 2 000 more people
working in general practice than we did
previously but also tens of thousands
more people more generally working in
primary care because there's lots of
different roles that can help you in
primary care now we'll be talking more
about this tomorrow but what we're
saying today is we want to invest
hundreds of millions of pounds in GP
practices to help end the 8am scramble
that's investing in new technology so
that people don't hear engage tones when
they call and that their core will be
dealt with on the day so they know what
is going to happen to them that's new
investment from the government going
into General practices to help end the
8am Scramble with new technology with
more to come tomorrow because we want to
make sure people can get the care that
they need as quickly as they need it
it's all part of our plan to cut waiting
lists BBC research has found that the
number of pharmacies in the country or
in England anyway has fallen by 160 over
two years I mean your mother's a
pharmacist you want to know a little bit
about this subject that sector needs
more money doesn't it to provide the
extra Services you wanted to well I care
deeply about Community Pharmacy my mum
was a pharmacist I worked in her
Pharmacy growing up I know how important
and Brilliant local pharmacists are up
and down our country we want to back
them tomorrow will be announcing more
plans to make sure that pharmacies have
the support that they need so they can
help more people and ease some of the
pressures in primary care I think all of
us know our local pharmacists we know
what a great job they do and me and the
government want to support them to do
even more to help us